sainte-rose cas qu'un bonjour bonjour
vous êtes candidat pour les élections
municipales macouba alors vous êtes déjà
maire vous êtes maire sortant et vous
avez été élu pour la première fois maire
de macumba en 1990 cela signifie que
vous avez cinq mandats à votre actif
alors pourquoi cette rose cas qu'un
tentez donc un sixième mandat
est ce que vous vouliez vous voudriez
par hasard battre le record martiniquais
aimé césaire qui était resté 50 ans on
le sait a maire de fort de france où est
ce que vous n'avez pas voulu ou
peut-être pas pu préparer une relève ou
non
peut-être que vous voulez tout
simplement être une sixième fois me mer
rien de tout cela tout simplement
répondre à une histoire d'amour une
histoire d'amour entre un enfant d'une
commune et sa commune une histoire
d'amour entre une population et une
équipe municipale
une histoire d'amour entre une équipe
municipale et celui qu'ils apprécient de
son maire tout simplement alors 30 ans à
la tête d'une commune est ce que
finalement un moment on ne s'en lasse
pas même si on aime beaucoup énormément
cette commune parce que ça doit pas être
tous les jours facile c'est pas une
sinécure
être mère par moments on se pose la
question et on se pose la question
surtout quand on est en face de
difficultés qu'ils deviennent pesantes à
macouba particulièrement ce drame qui
m'a conduit en ma qualité de maire
devant les tribunaux donc on y pense on
y réfléchit et quand on est dans une
histoire d'amour qu'on ne doit pas
trahir laisser abandonner ce serait
effectivement trahir cette population
qui a voulu d'un changement
et a voulu avoir comme édilité un enfant
de la commune comme équipe municipale
des enfants de la commune donc quand ça
ne va pas comme on le souhaite
ou comme on l'aurait souhaité on ne
réfléchit pas deux fois on se dit chez
marie pour lapider no hand in my la caf
et ma confiance mentalité là et pio donc
à continuer ensemble vous faire avancer
communaux donc pour vous la conviction
l'emportent sur la lassitude
si on comprend bien sainte-rose cac
alors on a dit vous avez trente ans de
mandature municipale mais vous avez été
élu en 1990 très jeune vous avez quel
âge
aujourd'hui on vous aurez quel âge en
2020 en mars 2020 moment-là que j'ai 62
ans et puis je serai entre les deux donc
vous aurez fait des 60 ans un peu plus
de 62 ans près de 63 ans
quel serait votre première urgence si
vous étiez réélu maire à 63 ans de
macumba quel serait votre première
urgence à la municipalité quel serait le
dossier prioritaire que vous prendriez
en main si vous étiez réélu le dossier
priorité l'a toujours été
la réconciliation du peuple de macumba
nous avons beaucoup souffert de cela
nous sommes allés à nous insulter
durant des campagnes et des campagnes et
aujourd'hui depuis la dernière mandature
on sent cette fusion qui est en train de
se faire qui c'est fait mais que l'on
voudrait parfait et le parfaire pourquoi
jusqu'à faut qu'ils aient un peu
d'opposition municipale quand même nom
mais cela s'entend je ne dis pas qu'il
ne faille pas d'opposition mais au moins
que cela se fasse avec respect ça n'a
pas toujours été le cas
j'ai moi-même été peut-être à l'origine
est peut-être un peu irrespectueux dans
ma jeunesse dans ma fougue mais avec
l'âge on s'assagit vous le dis nous
reste 30 secondes à se trouve kaka je
dis que pour faire avancer la commune et
bien
continuons à travailler ensemble parce
que la population de macumba aujourd'hui
est en train de rattraper tout ce
qu'elle avait comme motard pour réussir
le macumba 2 2 mais en dehors de
l'harmonie que vous voulez continuer à
réinstaurer c'est ce que vous dites est
ce qu'il ya un dossier je veux dire
technique
voilà quelque chose qui pour la commune
quoi est ce qu'il ya une urgence là un
chantier urgent presque difficile à
répondre parce que nous avions nous
avons mis en place toutes les
infrastructures nécessaires pour une
commune de la dimension de baqouba
aujourd'hui nous allons parfaire seul à
embellir la ville continue et la
réconciliation
et puis mettre à la disposition des
jeunes de demain des infrastructures qui
puisse nous permettent d'avancer dans la
voie du progrès merci sainte-rose cac 1
une émission réalisée par jean louis
gbangbo bonne journée à toutes et à tous